you've played as an action hero
you've even played as an anime
schoolgirl you played as an Italian
plumber but have you played everything
this game belongs to who's a lover six
[Music]
who's a lover six okay so it starts off
where you're in a little electron or
proton or neuron or think this is sad a
lot of stuff happening here
think again is there a point to this
it's a really a point to anything hello
darkness my old friend okay
whoa whoa it's not a cat I'm a cat I'm
what Puma or whatever they're called
amazing so we're playing as a Puma right
now hello darkness my old friend oh stop
stop stop stop stop
thank you what do they forget your
animates again
stop stop stop Puma
what is happening what is that
this is not how you walk it's not how
you walk you know what I would much
rather live in this world I would much
okay here we go
this is just this is the most realistic
Puma simulator game I have ever played
got him oh he's with me now hey mister I
don't know what animal you are so I'm
not gonna guess he's with me now we got
a friend okay got him
hey we're three now you're coming with
us
join the club hey you like the anti
walking
we got quite a following ok now we're
playing as a herd of animals I can't
walk straight amazing what is happening
Who am I and why am I here
they're disappearing ah we're back with
faith lonely puma all right all right
all right so you're supposed to be able
to control those are those beavers okay
here we go I can't seem to become the
beavers but I I can't become the plant
how the [ __ ] would that work yes yeah oh
my god damn plant finally a game that
represents who I died I identify with
driftwood I am a driftwood everyone I am
the best
I'm dude with three brick oh my god the
driftwood
he's gonna take over the universe join
us forest creatures drift boy we will
kill those foul humans oh we got palm
trees with the staff the palm trees have
joined us we must we will take over we
will take over this planet this planet
will be add our begin the trees the
trees have joined us
the trees from the West
we will conquer the driftwood will hello
mister dear would you like to join me in
my quest and world domination
excellent follow me
sheep and deer together forever they
will conquer the universe so if I can
place everything surely then I can play
as a shitty [ __ ] youtuber Jax but I
see oh my god yes we must find Jax /
dice hello Rock join us there rocks
would not miss it but I would not stop
sheep and deer sheep and they're
together forever the rock wouldn't join
them but that wouldn't stop them oh my
god the rock got deer deer yeah ha
that's the rocks got me don't become I'm
coming I'm coming to sing I'm coming to
say calm down I'm breaking up how do I
send you dear please say something
oh dear and together forever together
that will rule the galaxy
Darrin sheep they met a beaver yes I
will join you
beaver said and so they went up Darrin
cheap and beaver girl wherever they will
want to go no [ __ ] I'm driftwood now
goddamn it no I don't want to be I don't
want to be [ __ ] driftwood the lamb
Dyer hello Todd miss smile okay here we
go
it's an elk it's a [ __ ] out what the
[ __ ] is that sound uh uh okay you can't
go faster damn they're going fast
they had a mission to save this planet
to save this planet from Al Gore the
biggest threat to climate change after
of course Ainsley find a jacksepticeye
that's what they knew they had to do to
save the planet they find us a stick and
what the SEC said was shocking to say
the least
remember this players didn't understand
first keep in mind as you call beyond
you might need to find a way back but
they didn't listen they met another
coach
but it was retired they had who came up
with this videogame idea and why no I
expected that I could play us anything
but the whole you didn't tell me about
the whole part of the animals being
satanic beings oh my god they're tiny
baby Ahlers why are they so small now
the family Alex had had babies they were
pregnant all allowed
but this is what I want to do with
myself I just want to make a lot of
babies and then just send them out and
eat like an army you know that seems
like a viable planet I can make them do
all the kinds of [ __ ] Oh
together we are strong the goats have
joined is final
yeah
your highness
yah
far
yeah
where will it end
Bieber said what happens when we're too
many and everyone is with us okay the
mission a ticket
fine Jax
trees may not be with us the rocks may
be against but together we are strong
would you take over this planet but
suddenly they stopped it was like that
Forrest Gump episode when all the sudden
he just stopped running they became a
rock
[Music]
the rock okay
I'm playing as a rock here we go okay I
can ascend what what oh great I'm an
island
I'm a goddamn Island now I'm an island
everybody how you doing would you like
to join me other Island okay the other
Island is with me now excellent great
this is great moving across the ocean
this is the best life I have ever not
wanted to live I can play a sea grass I
am sea grass now everybody oh yes I
didn't expect to be sea grass I really
wasn't expecting to be to be sea grass
everyone all right well this is kind of
weird
I think I'll switch to I'm a planet I'm
a planet everyone excellent I'm planet
Earth let's crash that [ __ ] [ __ ] into
the Sun where is the Sun where there's
no Sun great oh there you are okay here
we go I am The Sun I am the one down
then the Sun don't sorry I'm sorry I'm
so sorry I'm so sorry
okay okay ascend I'm guessing a galaxy
I'm a galaxy I'm a galaxy everyone oh I
ascended the [ __ ] is this now I'm like
microscopic right whoa whoa what the
hell is happening it's sand green oh it
is isn't it what the [ __ ]
we're sand grains can transcend life
Oh I'm a cool pillar oh yeah oh boy
[Music]
we're getting me I can smell that son of
a [ __ ] and know he's close
come on boys faster
we're grass now we're [ __ ] grass all
right get the shrimps yeah boy assent
and we're back with Puma yeah hey
amazing no wait hey what's that on top
of the hill everything it was everything
I ever wanted and more check out the
game in the description it hasn't
actually come out yet and but I'm very
very interested in it and definitely
will get the get it when it comes out
cuz I think it's really cool original
and fun concept so props to the
developers for making something really
cool and unique I hope you enjoyed this
video if you did you know what to do